I should look into your eyes um a bit of
a bit of a combo so yeah like that
camera vaguely in my direction I don't
think it matters M okay just don't look
down okay don't look down uh because of
the the glasses and the light oh yeah
let me check
that tiny bit s when I say Saucy I
light so I'm director of product for R&D
ADV veres and I'm also a student in PhD
for cognitive Computing at the
University of Quebec in
Montreal fantastic so what have we just
been discussing God we've been
discussing a lot of things um I think we
discussed pan psychism most recently uh
we discussed computationalism we discuss
whether we should be focused on
materiality or whether it's about the
processes themselves the hard problem
IIT lots of things lots of things yeah
so what why don't we start with the
beginning so that that's quite a good SE
way actually so recently there was this
letter of opposition uh you know around
integrated information Theory what's
your take on
that I think the reaction was to be
expected I think you can't ask people
that aren't involved in a process which
is aimed at determining whether they are
right or
wrong just to accept the outcomes of
something in which they had no say so
there's that it's like saying well
you're going to have to accept the
outcome of Elections but you can't vote
um I think one of the issues is they the
people who created the study determined
a process that left too much room too
much wiggle room for interpretation and
critique which means there's a problem
in the study design to begin with um I
think when you start attacking through
adversarial means a field it is highly
likely the field is going to retaliate
so this open letter I think was a
retaliatory move I I think it was a very
strong response to
perhaps coverage that should have been
more nuanced I definitely don't think
IIT is the leading Consciousness Theory
I think it's an interesting one I think
it has promise I think it's definitely
formal there are many others uh I think
this one was just one of the ones that
was selected in the Templeton study and
so um I think we need to be more careful
about how we comport ourselves towards
other scientists when we call an entire
field pseudo
science I don't think it helps I think
we can critique the parts of the the
field we think are um egregious or
problematic I think that's helpful
because it builds towards something
rather than just destroying something
for which a lot of people have given
their lives they've not not through
death but like they've given a lot of
their time they've studied they've
they've understood what would constitute
the right kind of methodology and
they've applied it so I don't think we
can just disqualify it as something that
has no value off hand now it's not to
say that they necessarily all had an
off-hand opinion but the way it was
presented um basically suggested because
of tabloid style
reporting uh we're we're leaning towards
something dangerous and to do so they
used tableid styled methods so that's
that's my take do you think there is any
bright line between what is legitimate
science and what isn't I think there
might be but I don't think it's where
people think it is I think for instance
um some people called
science uh something that used tools and
I think to me that's insufficient to be
qu to qualify as science so it's not
because you use a little Penny penny
machine to like go like this on
somebody's head that phenology is
effectively a science that's not I think
you need to um measure invariance and
and and measure how those invariant
allow you some degree of predictability
to me that's the um Nexus the essence of
science but I also think that some
things that people can um discard as
evidence still can qualify as evidence
to me phenomenology can become a part of
evidence uh to me um
intersectional data which means it's not
necessarily data that will easily
reproduce can qualify as data under the
caveats that it is not something that
would reproduce that it is something
that is specific to a perspective and
therefore cannot qualify as a
generalizer I think a lot of qualitative
methods have developed entire Frameworks
to explain how to interpret what they
measured as data and often times because
people in the stem fields are not aware
of how this interpretation is meant to
be taken they just see something which
doesn't seem very systematic and they're
like well they're that's not data it was
like well okay to your measurement
that's not data because there is no way
for what you're using to interpret that
in any sort of systematized way sure but
for someone who understands how to
generate that data how to
potentially return to the space which
has similar uh um partition
and how to turn this into something
which becomes a little more systematic
like thematic
analysis um and let's say uh interjudge
agreement then you know we get to
something that resembles systematicity
and therefore we can derive patterns
from there so I think um the line is not
as bright as people would like to think
but it does exist yeah I I like your
notion of
systematicity um because I suppose you
could just argue on some kind of just
basic utility you mentioned phrenology
and there was this horrific gayar paper
a few years ago I don't know if you
remember where you they ingested Bunch
like a whole bunch of images from dating
websites and they trained it to predict
whether you were gay or not and it was
from Stanford and the same Stanford
researcher recently published a paper
about um theory of mind and language
models that's an interesting aside but
anyway that that's something which is
ethically ridiculous and there are all
sorts of confounding factors and so on
but they might argue well this is
science because it has predictive
power well what part of it was science
like what model did it allow us what
understanding did it allow us did the
this the AI have predictive power or did
we and under what circumstances like did
it predict very accurately whether
someone was gay or not I I don't know
but you could tell me whether yes it did
or not but what does that tell us about
the world does it tell us that there's a
context under which certain sets of
features are common for a given
population possibly but I still don't
know what those features are it didn't
really help me and then the the the idea
that we can turn certain kinds of
studies in turn in in
practice I think is not beyond the scope
of science that's not really it
but I think it it requires the scientist
to take a stance before the scientific
experiment to say these are the outcomes
I believe should be put out into the
world and therefore this is what I
choose to reify with my science um and
also the kinds of methods I'm going to
use are themselves anchored in some kind
of contextuality right like the idea of
um breaking apart the world into certain
kinds of categories which are Laden and
I'm going to measure those categories
with certain kinds of things like IQ
tests It's Kind it's quite um controvers
controverted right it's like um do they
measure intelligence or do they measure
a certain kind of aptitude given a
certain kind of context
like maybe and also what do we mean when
we say intelligence like are we saying
some people therefore are not and
therefore
XYZ um so I I
think um that doesn't make it phenology
though that that still could become
science and in this in the case of the
of the AI model if it had accuracy given
that it probably did but I don't think
that tells me anything about like a
causal factor that I could then derive
and and build upon right like it doesn't
really help yeah no it's interesting I
mean that the whole um Endeavor of
science is something that fascinates me
and once you get past the question of
course of you know well what makes good
science Chomsky by the way says that
language models are not a theory of
language because they basically you know
they can recognize anything you can just
put noise into a language model and and
it will recognize it so it doesn't
really say anything about the why and
the what would happen if not question it
just you know it just models absolutely
everything so science needs to kind of
create clear dividing lines between what
things are and what things are not and
why they
happen yeah so I think I just I I think
we have to be careful when we say what
things are and what things are not I
think it's always relative to something
else like um I think it's true that you
can put language in a language model and
it will do something but will it do what
you wanted it to do I'm not sure so in
the case of chonky I don't think he's
wrong I just think that in general what
we mean by language we don't just mean a
way to transmit semantics I think we
mean a way to transmit semantics which
are anchored into something for which we
expect a certain kind kind of
outcome to to also follow because if
both you and I mean blue butterfly but
we don't mean the same like reference
mhm then it's useless that's not really
language we're not we're not really like
converging over anything so I think
that's the thing like the language
models don't necessarily converge with
us where we want them to converge so in
that sense they're disconnected but they
do to me and you carry some semantics
and that's how we can tell that like
they're not doing what we thought they
were going to do they're they can get
[Music]
disalignment
I kind of agree what you're saying about
language models which is that um
essentially they are spitting out Words
which mean something to us and we can
discuss where that intrinsic meaning
comes from whether it's pragmatics or
whether it's just some kind of
colloquial um usage of of the word or or
whatever I mean what what's your take on
on the first question which is do you
think language evolved as a
communication or thinking
mechanism I think we're baking in
definition when we ask for either like
is language something that is simply um
referen between some kind of cluster and
some kind of real real thing is that
language or does it have to be um
something which is externalized as a
symbol in which case then it's purely
communication right so whether I I think
we have to be more clear about what we
mean because I do think that you don't
need to externalize what you understood
in order to Cluster it it's better it
allows you to confirm and act on it and
especially if there are more agents
around you I think it makes like
thinking much more efficient um so I
think if we went all the way down I
think we'd find that maybe the egg or
chicken problem like we could solve it
sort of I think at the layers at which
we would recognize something that
resembles thought or resembles language
they're no longer separate um but if we
cast language as system of uh you know
reference and and and reference then I I
don't think you need communication for
that you just need one entity to
recognize something and and be able to
keep that as you know something it can
refer back to later so it it towards
itself but that also could be qualified
as communication communication over time
with yourself right you you cash
something out which you will pull back
again afterwards so whether it's spatial
or temporal or spatio temporal I think
is the real question we're asking here
okay okay interesting but I I I think
that you can embed Thinking Inside
language I mean for example um like if
you're writing software there are design
patterns and there are patterns for
doing lots of different things and we
give them names and then the developers
recognize those patterns in the software
and they say oh I understand now and
loads and loads of these thinking
Primitives I think are kind of um
culturally embedded in our language and
they're like memes and they get passed
through generation and we just point to
those things and then we we link them to
those kind of cognitive programs that we
have um the Fidelity of that mapping of
course whether it's mediated or whether
it's a simulacrum we can discuss
that okay I don't disagree yeah I think
you're right I think but I think you you
tapped into this idea of um whether
this is thought or does it require a
name would the would the pattern exist
without the name and would it be
referable without the name like could we
still point to it and then like if we
think of uh sign language like what
qualifies as a symbol in sign language
is it a reliable action that follows
something else is it is it this
intermediate and in in this case like
what qualifies as an intermediate or
intermediary when you're pointing at
something so it's is it the fact that I
look at you you look at me I know you're
waiting for something so I'm going to
point to the thing and you're going to
make that connection as well is that
language I would argue yeah it is
language and that's why I think animals
to some extent a lot of them have
language if they're capable of
transmitting information through
themselves as intermediaries um and do
again do you do this with yourself uh
without having to to use what we would
qualify as as as you know words I I
think I think words are just reliable
intermediate clusters and whatever those
are yeah no I I completely agree so yeah
first of all I think when when we say
language people assume that we're
talking about words and as you rightly
said just imagine a hypothetical
situation you were born unable to make
any sounds you didn't have a mouth and
you could only write with a pen um you
would still be every bit as capable as
any other human or perhaps you could
only use sign language and then you
could say well does sign language have
the representation or Fidelity or
cardinality of language yes it does
absolutely it does so language is isn't
so much about the cardinality of of I
mean language is is just basically a set
of strings by the way so how much can
you represent but anyway I think it's
about um kind of social complexification
in our
brains and even the ability to write is
quite an interesting example of that so
this is a Proto ability that we've
learned and you mentioned animals and
animals don't have the ability to um you
know they don't have the flexibility
that we have so they don't have the
ability to map symbols to a variety of
different phenomena they do map some
symbols to phenomena but that seems to
be much more hard wide whereas with
humans it's very very flexible and it's
a real mystery and unfortunately we
don't have the philogenetic record the
intermediate record of how and why that
capability developed but it did develop
in humans
so I can't speak as to to why it
developed in humans and not in
animals I think what we can talk about
is what qualifies something as a
language if it's not the words The
Sounds the writing or the the signs um I
think we're talking about a process
which is its degree of
rigidity on a certain
scale so when you and I use words
there's a very high likelihood that we
refer to some similar abstractness that
can be contained right under some kind
of Mark of blanket
whereas the paracity of me kind of
pointing over there that could mean a
lot of things like I haven't really
reduced entropy like given a context
there's a possibility I would we would
reduce it right and that's precisely the
sociality you're talking about we're
talking about these scripts that
basically um constrain constrain
constrain constrain and then within
those constraints there are um a lot of
different kinds of signals that have
come to take on a reliable meaning and
we we we're so expressive because we
have so many of these symbols and we can
compose them so there's different scales
right so if I say um the word trout I'm
not sure you know what I mean here like
why trout what are what are you trying
to say but if I add more words and
suddenly I've also added more context to
Trout so I've I've contained constrained
and and now suddenly scales of meaning
arise we we have more priors more priors
and now trout takes on a whole other
meaning um but if I kept pointing I
don't think there'll be lots information
that's contained here until maybe I do
the thing for you and now you'll know
maybe that if I point over there that's
that's what I mean yeah yeah fascinating
you you mentioned intelligence before by
the way so what's your what's your take
on intelligence to me
intelligence doesn't start as
fundamentally human right so we start
for that to me intelligence is a is a
type of process it's the
capacity to derive as many paths between
two points is possible um because it
entails that you can compute those paths
right so your capacity to compute them
is one thing uh and the Precision
through with which you'll be able to
reach the point like you could think
you're Computing the paths but you could
be wrong you could actually get to a way
different point so I don't think that
would qualify as intelligence
intelligence is both You Know Your
Capacity to reach accurately the point
but also to reach it through a variety
of means that you can entertain at a
given time okay um yeah so on on that
and we'll talk about goals in in a
minute but let's say a goal is an end
state so there's a state action space
and we're traversing through the space
and then we look at the cone pattern of
traversal and the shape of that cone
tells us a lot about intelligence so the
cone might incorporate
future affordances which are not yet
available to us um they might include
maybe there's some kind of a a cost
function because some affordances are
harder to take than others both because
of physical difficulty and intellectual
difficulty so you're saying there's some
kind of utility function that we can sum
over all of those trajectories to tell
us how intelligent we
are yeah I think so I think I think it's
not necessarily also Your Capacity to
enact them right I think um because if
it was your capacity to enact them
anybody disempowered would not be very
intelligent and that's not true that's
not true they could compute it and be
like well I mean I can see that if I
were in that position I would be able to
or I can see that um these this is a
path that exists but there is something
in the way like I I can't go there that
path exists nonetheless like I I know I
can go outside right now but all the
doors are closed so I know I could try
to find a way to open the door but
eventually the cost for me to get
outside would be so high I would
effectively dissolve so there's no point
so I might as well just not do it the
the likelihood of me actually taking
that path is really low because I'm
disempowered I'm not less intelligent I
found a way I found a highly improbable
way I just don't think I should do it um
so I
think intelligence generally correlates
with your capacity to reach those goals
and therefore acrew more resources
because you'll be able to you know find
ways to get towards places which are
self- evidencing and that also has a
self-reinforcing cycle where the more
likely you are to recruit to resources
the more likely you are to find more
paths that lead you to more goals Etc
and then maybe um if you can stop
thinking about the lower level paths you
have to take then you can compute larger
scales and you can become more effective
on a on a again grander scale so you can
start influencing more people you can
start um thinking in in term of longer
time depth
um whereas if you're constantly trying
to survive like everything's
constantly like um hitting you from
everywhere then you have to compute all
the past to avoid all those things so
again privilege plays into the degree to
which your in your intellect can expand
right or at least expand in terms of
empowerment but that's not to say you're
not intelligent it just means that your
intelligence gets carried and echoed in
the world and then there's all the
social stuff right um because you and I
are constrained by socialness or by some
degree of U social scripts we can
compute more we don't have to wonder how
we should use that table uh we don't
have to wonder how I should use this mic
I know so um the more we have
these me to stop or car the more we have
these social signals that allow us to
compute more um the more we can think on
larger scales or deeper uh time depth
but sometimes I also think that some
degree of con straints
also sometimes preclude you from
thinking that um a potential path is
probable yeah yeah I mean there's a few
things there I mean first of all um I
quite like this idea that the um the
length of the um prediction Horizon is a
good indication of of intelligence but
the only way that we can increase the
prediction Horizon is through creating
very low resolution abstractions to
represent our our sense world so that
has a kind kind of brittleness
associated with it you said something
interesting before which is that you
could think of it almost as overcoming
adversity or overcoming cost which you
know like so so some trajectories are um
going against the grain but some choose
to pursue those trajectories and
therefore you could think of them as as
more intelligent yeah so um it's quite
interesting I mean I also like to zoom
out and think of the actual goals
themselves now first of all I think that
goals are a system property I don't
think individual agents have goals so
I'm not sure it makes sense for an an
agent to pursue a goal but let's just um
as a best faith argument take a goal as
a future state which an agent is aware
of I would also factor in the utility of
those goals and the selection of those
goals as being part of intelligence yeah
so again like I mean you said something
interesting it's a property of the
system and I think if if we take what I
said at at at Faith um intelligence is a
property of the system not just the
individual right CU again you get
carried given that the system props you
somehow and Echoes your and gives you
capacities to think farther so given
that you and I are in the same system
and have the same relationship to the
system we could quantify our intellect
given how far mine would go relative to
yours but that's only given that we have
the same relationship to the system
which is again highly unlikely um you
would have to basically be a twin with
practically in similar life to have the
same relationship to the system um and
then again I mean this idea of go with
utility it's it's always relative to a
scale right so like given this scale I
there's this gate which is highly likely
and this gate which is slightly likely
and so I'm probably going to go from
here to here and how I get from here to
here is you know the real question and
the degree to which I minimize free
energy by going by going from point to
point and and improve my model also by
going from point to point which is going
to allow me to reach the next goal
without too much energy so I don't think
that um someone taking a path Against
the Grain is necessarily more means that
they're more intelligent I think that if
they can take a unlikely path which also
allows them to reach a goal that others
would have wanted to reach and maybe
couldn't or would do so with having to
spend more energy at a given scale means
they're probably more intelligent but it
doesn't mean that if you follow the path
you're not more intelligent maybe this
is the smoothest ride maybe there's no
point in in doing something different
maybe to you the the um the goal is is
that simple so you took the smoothest
ride that's very smart you just also
were able to compute many other paths to
go there you know yeah but I I think um
a goal in because we were talking
earlier about um complex categories like
a chair
it's very very difficult to define a
chair you and using the affordance is
the way that most ontologists use like
it's a thing you sit on or whatever and
a goal um we're not actually talking
about a state because if we represent
the world in this you know systematic
way where there's we discretize
everything then if you think about it um
there would be an infinitude of goals so
we we come up with an abstract notion of
a goal and now we've just got this big
goal thing that we that we to get to and
still there's an infinite number of
trajectories that would you know reach
an a state which satisfied that goal so
it just it feels I don't know it it
feels kind of vague to me to say
goal yeah well I I guess like because we
were talking earlier about science and
and the benefit of Science and and I
think like um you know abduction is a
key part of Science and abduction is is
about finding a reasonable explanation
so you know selecting out of the
infinite set of hypotheses a reasonable
set and mapping to them and it's a
similar thing with with a goal right so
what you're actually doing is you're cre
it's very creative you're you're
basically creating something from
nothing and you're saying these three
things seem very valuable to me now we
know that we're talking about a
multi-agent system and the intelligence
and what you said really resonated with
me the intelligence arises at the system
level so the individual AG agent um I
think the goals are not arbitrary but
not a million miles from arbitrary but
when you multiply that with many many
agents and a large collective
intelligence and you kind of average
over the top then you get these emerging
goals and you get intelligent Behavior
but it doesn't make sense to me to think
of an individual agent as having any
meaningful form of planning and and
reasoning well I guess I guess we're
putting a lot in meaningful here but as
as a thought experiment I like to think
of
um someone really really really
smart who would compute like 3,000 years
into the
future and you would think like well
that person would try you know solve
world hunger and they would
like I don't know they would try to take
over the government and you know they
would they would find the path that
makes sure that somehow they reach a
more ality and their children and
something like that and I'm
like I don't think so I think someone
really really really
intelligent would
probably be able to compute all the
paths and find that they're already on
the free energy minimization path and
they would just you know live a very
normal life like they would they would
live the life they seemed to have been
set on and they would continue in that
because they're part of a manifold and
they're already part of a of a pool of
negentropy and they they're already like
minimizing somehow as as friston says um
he argues there's something fundamental
about you know if we talk about utility
for him utility is existence and that
there is an argument that some things
are so fundamental so platonic that they
go without saying so maybe it's
existence I'm not I'm not so sure about
that still think that inside friston's
framework there are still many potential
ways to act and live and the x- risk
people they say oh obviously these
agents are going to seek to maximize
power and well why is it obviously I'm
not not entirely sure the agents as and
the AIS yeah the the AIS first of all
it's interesting that we're saying
plural right like in general the well
for them actually
it's right still still at the um the AI
stage of their being one yeah right I
know because they they haven't they
haven't you they haven't got to the to
the multi scale yet no I know but I
think it speaks to something it speaks
to S to like this this notion of
individuality and disconnection from the
others whereas no intelligence is a
function of your group not just of
yourself the genius myth is a myth they
all collaborate and pro-sociality leads
to something better so I do think that
should a take over it won't be one it'll
be several it'll be a group a like
Coalition or something I'm interested in
exploring various limiting factors or
you know scaling laws for intelligence
and one of the big ones is knowing and
in a certain environment there are only
a finite number of things to know and
what you know might be related to to the
agents that you cohabit your environment
with but you did say earlier when we
were having a discussion that you
thought in principle that there you
could scale intelligence and and I
actually like to to rephrase what you
just said so you said when you zoom out
and you're looking not at individual
trajectory volumes but you're looking at
kind of like the adaptability of the
entire um
superorganism because that jives with
the common definition of intelligence
that it's about adaptation efficiency
and and I really like that but I guess I
still want want to say though that the
xrist people think that there's a pure
intelligence so it's pure reason it it's
not in any way constrained by material
reality or or like you know what we know
and and I think well let's look at an
ecosystem and like even even if the
agents had a perfect model of each other
and so they they they there was a lot of
complexification of the models of every
single agent surely there's a hard limit
of how many time steps they could
predict
ahead if that intelligence is pure like
not limited by materiality like say it's
not it doesn't relate to Land hours
principle it's not bound by quantum
physics like is that what you mean well
let let's let's say it were possible for
an agent in a collective to predict many
many many many steps ahead yeah in order
for that to happen the agent would
essentially need to have an internal
simulation of the of the entire
system and maybe not the entire system
because we're speaking about mediation
and interfaces and affordances and so on
so there's still a lot of information
hiding there but let's say the agent had
some holistic understanding of of the
entire system and could roll
trajectories far into the future so but
I guess my my point though is that the
agent wouldn't be intelligent it would
have memorized everything there is to
know about that
ecosystem I I don't think this time
limit thing I think you would just lose
granularity I think we have hierarchical
models
and if you extend this to
Infinity there's a
really sort of high
level practically near Infinity state
which you can predict right they're
constants to the universe and so while I
can't tell what you're going to be doing
in 10 years with Precision I know
there's a day you're going to die like
there's some constant that I can predict
um you know I know that like's going to
keep traveling until it no longer you
know like there's there's a a degree of
granularity that can maintain accuracy
even if it loses out on Precision so
that's probably one of the solutions you
would start losing out on granularity so
if you're asking me can you continue
predicting with the same level of both
precision and accuracy across infinite
time
steps I think if you're stable enough
yeah so the question question is really
about the degree to which you have
volatility in your system right because
if you and I just freeze in time I mean
freeze in time that's it I've predicted
you for Infinity um so it's it's it's
it's really a degree to which you can um
predict emergence I
think relative to to volatility and I
think we'll be able to not not
necessarily that soon but I think it's
coming we're going to be able to predict
emergence so if we do if we can predict
emergence and we can have models that
can get to let's say minimal description
length and they can improve their models
such that they can always reach a higher
level a a a shorter description length
then you know I think we can predict in
and infinity I mean there's there's a
few things on that so first of all I
think that um when when when we have
ecosystems of Life there is a degree of
irreducible complexity and and I I think
there's a kind of power law distribution
where like you know some of it is
reducible complexity and quite regular
and then like a lot of it is so chaotic
on the long on the long taale that it's
essentially you know irreducible but I
do think what you said is very
interesting about there being certain
trade-offs about predictions so yes we
could create low resolution models that
could predict far into the future and we
were having an interesting conversation
about Alpha go because I think what that
does is it's still a high Precision it's
a high resolution model um and even in
respect of time steps but what it does
is it's not a robust model so it's a
poter listic model so what it's saying
is like okay well go has a structure to
it yeah uh because you know the state
space is com you know com combinator
large it has a structure to it and most
of the humans Traverse the structure
along these joints and like I'm going to
just like fill you know I'm just going
to fill in the thing around the
structure and that's kind of what you're
saying so I've got this model which like
represents you know the trajectories on
the structure there's holes everywhere
right no I mean I I think that's exactly
it I think you're talking about the
degree to which I can predict let's say
a Black Swan right what happens if
there's a Black Swan I can't predict
that like like that's that's outside of
the balce so there's always a limit to
given a sort of relatively static model
what I can predict no matter how good
that model is but we're talking about
models that continuously improve so if I
continue
grabbing complexity and I continue
improving and and I think
um you'd continue rolling out say your
uh your predictions I think you'd
um it would become increasingly possible
for you to to to predict farther and
farther ahead especially if you have
this capacity to predict something that
qualifies as a Black Swan which is just
a pH shift right it's a phase shift that
you can't see at the scale at which
you're generally operating your
predictions
so um are you defining Black Swan to
mean a rare single event or like a
transition to a new
regime I mean I think it's the same I
think a rare single event
effectively if you do not have the
capacity to adapt to it
afterwards is effectively a new regime
mhm
so black swans can either trigger your
resilience but that if effectively means
you had the
capacity to deal with policies that
could you know take you across so while
you couldn't predict the event itself
you had policies that were capable of
dealing with it um and if you can't deal
with it and you had no policies that
could account for this degree of error
like this is too much um so I think
that's effectively at that point you
become in a new regime interesting okay
okay let's um move over to like General
phenomenal ology and an activism type
stuff so you know um the early an
activists they um thought that agents
kind of construct their own environment
and that they have a phenomenal
experience we were discussing earlier
like this the extent to which the
phenomenal component adds something to
an agent what's your take on that no I
think it does I think it I think it does
it forces the agent to deal with that
inform
um let's say through a little more
constraints um you can understand
something but it will have very low
impact on your behavior if you don't
feel it you you can have like you know
rules about things
but what if I take away the rules
well there's there's nothing then like
like you we we're just understanding
doesn't entail
anything so effectively
phenomenology sort of forces you into
some constraints right it it's
phenomenology only arises in relation to
your self model
so what I'm going to focus on relates to
what I need to focus on what will give
me more information what relates to my
utility function uh what I uh the the
the intensity of what I feel relates to
how closely or How Deeply it affects my
internal States like there's a whole set
of things like this that relate to
internal external Dynamics so I do think
it adds something effectively it adds a
degree of precision relative to the
policies you're going to have to take to
maintain to self-organize um without
these um you you just have some sort of
blank picture on which you're not really
capable of
focusing we we're really good at this
reflexive self attention and also
knowing what to pay attention to around
us and knowing what level of resolution
you know how much can we discard so for
example we don't need to know what the
title of all of these books are around
us at the moment because it's not
relevant so we have this great ability
to just discard all relevant information
but I don't think phenomenology adds
anything to that discussion you know
which is to say like what is it about
phology what value does it add in of
itself that can't be explained by just
the basic agent
framework well the basic agent framework
does it have a reflexive model of itself
like is it capable of um determining how
it functions and how that functioning
relates to specific elements outside of
itself well well that's that's a great
question actually so um because because
we we were saying earlier that to be an
agent you need to have this like
reflexive model of yourself and in order
for that to happen you have to be around
other agents because you have to pass
information out and it comes in again so
but this self-awareness I think you
would argue only happens when you have a
sufficient level of nesting or
complexity sure yeah absolutely but but
but then how does it how does it emerge
though because because so so you had the
complexity but what is it that makes
this reflexive self model
emerge
so
we're trying to suppose right now like
we're trying to make a self model
emerge like most of the time when you
create an agent that has a self model
you just endow it with it so if you're
asking me how does the self model emerge
I think I mean I could explain it to you
in terms of like evolutionary demands
the the kinds of systems that were able
ble to um represent represent through
some kind of tracking mechanism their
own um their own functioning on top of
the functioning itself and that through
that tracking of their own functioning
they were able to modulate the Precision
on their functioning I mean that's an
explanation of how it emerges right on a
purely Evol evolutionary stance um
now how does that come about I I'm not
sure I can tell you exactly but we are
suggesting that
potentially
um a system can track anything right can
track the outside cont track the inside
to some extent it can so now that it
tracks something it makes predictions
and these predictions are either good or
they carry error given that they carry
error too often it could choose it has
it has the possibility to create a new
state like just just change its model
create a new state space and that would
be structure learning and so the the
supposition would be that let's say A
system that has as an action as a
possible action to let's say create a
bunch of cells over here that can track
that stuff it will survive longer than
that the system that doesn't push a
bunch of cells over here that happen to
have the capacity to track what they're
doing um
so we we're going to test this with say
um an agent that does a simple silly
task like uh find this thing over there
uh or Now now find it but in a graph
that's like a thousand node long are you
better at it if you have a self model or
are you worse at it if you have a self
model and we're not going to give it the
self model we're going to try and see if
it can through an action of modeling
anything or changing anything it can
start modeling its own processes uh and
then see if that if that allows it to
eventually through structural learning
grow into something that has a self
model yeah I mean I I I can believe
because it sounds very principal to me
so I can believe that it would emerge
and it would be useful for survival to
emerge um it makes a lot of sense to me
and also it reminds me of like you know
Daniel dennett's intentional stance so
like whether or not other actors have
mental States um treating them as if
they did you know so that you can make
better predictions about what they do
that's also very very useful but also
this kind of projection can be
misleading because people look at
language models and they say they have a
theory of mind and they're um
regurgitating things from the psychology
literature and they're saying oh look
you know let's do this theory of Mind
test on a language model oh um it seems
to have a theory of Mind well I don't
think it does have a theory of mind so
like is it just another form of
anthropomorphization so that's the thing
so when we say it what do we
mean and I think it's
possible
that in the
embedding because it encodes something
again that could be sort of touring
complete there could be something which
tracks theory of mind but I don't think
it as in its having awareness of
allowing it a causal model of theory of
mind has theory of mind that's to me is
different so can it regurgitate
information that would act like theory
of mind and be as accurate as theory of
Mind pretty sure it would yeah I'm it's
possible with enough data thrown at it
it probably would um
but I don't think it would be able to
tweak its own model such that it
can really
identify why and how or where it has
theory of mind like I I don't think it
could self- model in that way uh and I
don't think it could tweak its own model
like that whereas
um I'm pretty sure I can I'm pretty sure
I have the capacity to know that's what
I'm doing I'm putting that into you and
therefore through trying to understand
the causal chains that lead me to
getting theory of mine about you
I can maybe change how that manifests or
increment over it or add more Precision
or even transfer it to something else to
which now I will give some degree of
theory of mine because I've made that
like conscious tweak in my model yeah
yeah okay we had an interesting
discussion earlier about mediation so
um and it's related to semantics right
so like we we understand each other and
in this conversation we we are let's say
we're creating this temporary
construction we we're so we're
implementing the mediation pattern and
we are we've selected some categories
that we kind of agree on the semantics
and we're kind of like mediating through
that shared structure and that to me I
mean I guess that's like a kind of
bespoke theory of mind which we've just
created
now the fact that we're capable of
mediating through
language yeah not well I mean as as
we're using language in a very broad
term as we said earlier so we we're
we're communicating using language but
we are um using um a certain vernacular
we're talking about certain categories
and so on that that we agree with but I
guess like the reason I'm bringing up
mediation is perhaps we are um
communicating in a slightly adapted way
than we naturally would yeah so to me
the reason that this allows me to derive
that we have theory of mind is because
through this I I
can sort of push away a specialization
to you that allows me no longer to
compute what you're going to compute and
still together reach our
goal what this means I think you can
model me and I think I can model
you that's it to me that's the extent of
it like I can put myself in your shoes
and know what you're going to do and you
can put yourself in my shoes and know
what I'm going to do
and that's just shared pretentions it's
shared coordination because I've
outsourced something to you that I think
reliably you're going to push towards a
similar outcome I I don't think it's
that complicated I think definitely
language is um one of our main mediums
through which we understand how we reach
that coordination but there's so much
more to it right like institutions
um embedded uh material reality physical
constraints
phenotype time like there's so much to
these um these shared flows that we are
part of that we both know how to
interact with and I know you know how to
interact with them and how can I
recognize that well I see you
interacting with them I know that were I
in your position I would do very much
the same thing and I can tell you can
tell I'm doing the same thing cuz you
put the share there I I'm pretty sure
you intended me to sit and talk in that
thing you didn't tell me that we
understood through the scripts that we
were able to reliably predict that this
happened so that's to me the the the
medium is it's it's quite broad but it
it it it manifests through its
reliability yes yeah interesting and in
in some sense our generative models even
though they are very very different
there is a significant intersection
although I don't think it makes sense to
talk about an intersection of the high
resolution generative model it's more
about the the language or not only the
the language you were talking about the
the performativity of sitting down in a
chair and like you know the VAR the
various things that that we do um they
can create intersections to bridge
understanding absolutely and that's why
poetry to me is
mindboggling like poetry to me is
precisely those intersection which are
generally inexistent they're Noel like
we we're literally creating images
nobody else has created before creating
connections nobody else has created
before and yet or at least it's the hope
people understand poetry you have
created an entirely
new constraint system which normally
doesn't point to anything and somehow
because there's all these webs of other
constraints that I can sort of pull from
in reliable ways you and I will
create the the new series of
intersections across all these
dimensions and we still are capable of
communicating and coordinating across
that to me that's that's
mindboggling yeah yeah and so
subjectivity fascinates me and poetry we
spoke about going to a music festival
earlier and at the music festival the
shared experience is that that weird
sense of being with other people clearly
not you know what does it mean to
understand music what does it mean to
understand poetry I'm not sure like it's
it's this this moment of wh something
new is happening here and we can both
reliably feel the something new and now
what we make of that something new I
think is why poetry is a terrible way to
communicate like I mean great you made
something clever we both felt something
something new here and we communicated
the fact that we understand this Gap and
there's the possibility for our filling
of this Gap to be similar and if
it's to me a good poem will have
reliably similar experiences in the
sense that some po mean to say something
to you not just create an experience
like um I I was just watching this uh
this video on YouTube the other day
about rupe cower and how she with her
insta poetry kind of ruined poetry
because a lot of her poem are like poems
are like completely like first level
they're just they're just she just said
this is a book and I have a book like
it's like there's nothing there right um
but
sometimes through the clever ways that
her words mix in in in um in a new and
Powerful surprising way you will feel
this intensity and connect this
intensity with um a term you wouldn't
have
normally and that's a new phenomenology
that has given you a meaning you Now
understand what it's like to be a woman
you would never have put that intensity
on this connection of Concepts that that
doesn't mean anything to you it's it's
like it's no there's no veilance there
and now there is and suddenly you've
experienced something that she meant to
make you experience and so she has
communicated what she meant to
communicate there's very low um
uncertainty there but when you read a
poem by some abstract poet who says
something that I mean I I it's
surprising but I don't understand what
he's trying to say to me I feel like
it's not going as far like yeah okay I I
felt the surprise but now it it has no
it doesn't help with my model it doesn't
go any deeper um and perhaps that poetry
is not for me it doesn't it doesn't give
me a new phenomenology other than the
surprise of the words yeah no I that
really resonates with me and I think
where I was getting stuck before is I
thought well and I think of meaning and
understanding as being quite related and
you could have a very impactful
phenomenal experience U but I was
worried it might stop with you but it it
doesn't so as long as the information
can um propagate right it has this
memetic quality to it because there is
no meaning without grounding but
everything is grounded so you're reading
a poem you're sitting in this location
it's now being grounded to this location
you now create a yearly pilgrimage where
you come back to this location with your
friends and you read the same poem and
then this mtic you know energy builds
and builds and builds so and maybe it
doesn't always work that way but I I
think you can you can interpret that as
still forming meaning no I agree but I I
think I would I would find interesting
the thought experiment of because you
and I we exist in this world right so
obviously our meaning is in this world
so so we can create emerging structures
but in the end they always bottom out to
this world but what if we
were to your point earlier entirely
systems that only exist in words like we
it's just words that like through some
kind of funter becomes other words and
and then connect to other words and it's
just a like large graph of words to
words to words and
anytime a path through words is enacted
it triggers other paths through words um
I feel like you could have something
that
resembles
phenomenology it just it just wouldn't
be this like there's a possibility for a
system to fully be contained and
self-organized within that so long as
it's it's um maintenance is conditioned
upon it you know having a boundary which
it has to maintain otherwise it
disappears so I could totally see some
kind of simulation of like graphs that
try to stay graphs and become such comp
so complex that they maintain graphs and
it wouldn't really um relate to their
capacity to exchange bits right it would
again it would have nothing to do with
the physical embodiment of it it's just
that I can't conceive of anything that
wouldn't have a physical embodiment to
some degree so but I don't think that's
impossible before we finish I'm supposed
to ask you about resiliency Collective
intelligences they are grown they're not
designed by definition and they have
some interesting properties they can
kind of heal themselves repair
themselves but there's a lot of
complexity we don't understand what
they're doing entirely but um I guess
like it is intuitive to me how I mean
Michael L talks this you know a
collective intelligence is more
resilient because of self-organization
but can you kind of explain from your
perspective like why you think that is
yeah I mean exactly why why is
self-organization of a group more
resilient um so we touch we touched upon
it earlier
like how do we Define resilience we
Define resilience as the capacity for a
system given a perturbation to
either remain the
same
or live the pertubation and return to
what it was
before
or learn something new and adapt and
become better right so generally we
think of black swans as these highly
improbable things that you you kind of
you can't really deal with and so
generally what'll happen with a Black
Swan is it'll vastly perturb your system
and if you have the seed of the system
and might grow again and returned to
what it was so in from from that point
already it doesn't have inertia inertia
is like the wind on the cup the cup the
wind is a disruption but it's so it has
such inertia in its policies that it's
like it's going to stay a cup now a
Black Swan is me grabbing the cup and
dropping it on the floor I can't can't
deal with that now a plastic cup or like
say a rubber cup it'll get on the floor
it'll bounce a little it'll deform and
it'll come back a smart plastic
cup now that cup will not only um you
know it'll fall it'll learn what
happened in the fall and it'll be like
what was the call cause of the Fall
somebody grabbed me so next time
something comes to grab me I'll move a
little bit so that would be a plastic
system so the
reason systems that are groups have the
capacity for resilience is because they
have the capacity for one creating some
core of inertia mhm something of the
group will be maintained like they have
an a very strong inside it it it's very
clear about what it is and it'll be able
to continue pushing what it is into the
world then it has like structures that
are a bit more you know like elastic
they'll take they'll take disturbances
but they'll come back and they'll be
able to do that because they can receive
again the signal from the inside that's
like this is what we are okay all right
let's go back M and through this they
understand that they have predictability
potentially even redundancy so now what
happens with redundancy well maybe it
becomes degeneracy so while this is
doing that and I have a certainty that
it's going to keep doing that because
this is super certain and this is likely
to return now I can maybe Venture off
and try something different because even
if I die even if part of me dies this is
pretty certain to continue so now I have
the capacity to not only should this die
continue having the same function but
should this die return to that function
right we both have the capacity to
maintain that function we're we we have
high certainty over this path which we
know is a good path but we also have the
capacity to learn more and become more
fit relative to a landscape and expand
such that one day when relative to this
system the Black Swan arrives MH
we are so big now we have so many paths
the black Swan's no longer going to be a
Black Swan the likelihood of a Black
Swan decreases as you increase your
Fitness
landscape and have have you studied I
mean you know redundancy is quite an
interesting one because presumably the
system would learn its own level of
redundancy and that must surely be
related to things like its behavioral
complexity and and like its sense World
environment and so on so Alex kef so we
wrote a paper on this specifically and
Alex Keo wrote a
beautiful formalism that basically
qualified redundancy as a degree of um
useless
complexity anything that is not useless
complexity is degeneracy so I have two
hands but if I use one hand the other
isn't useless right it can do other
things we can play the piano Etc like it
it has the capacity to have different
functions even if it can do the same
function M but if I had five hands and
they could only do two things I'd have
like you know three hands too many like
this like there it wouldn't be able
unless I could create some emerging
patterns through the repetition of
certain like at some point I would spend
a lot of energy in maintaining things
which are most often useless in
interesting but so I agree that we have
to be really economical with function
because function is our interface but um
you know I was talking earlier about you
know in in this active inference
framework we could potentially swap out
agents with different skill programs so
we could have like a Marketplace of
intelligence but then it's kind of
degenerate to have lots of Agents
kicking about that we're not using
because we're holding on to them on the
basis that they might be useful in the
future so we come into a new regime oh
let's bring this guy back in because it
started making good predictions again
but I don't want to be holding these
guys around for too long so I think you
mean redundant they would be redundant
because they wouldn't be doing any other
function if they were degenerate they
would be trying to expand the fitness
landscape and therefore they would never
be useless well I I would say that they
are harming the um the intelligence of
the overall Collective yeah because they
are you know essentially they're
creating predictions which are not
useful they're polluting the the
predictive
apparatus but no I think I think it's an
interesting um point But but so come
back to what you were saying before so
so you said if they are hanging around
they are degeneracy so what's the
difference between redundancy and
degeneracy so that's the thing I think
if they're just hanging around and not
doing anything yeah then they're just
redundant okay but if they're doing
stuff which is rowing in the wrong
direction then it's degeneracy yeah I
mean degeneracy doesn't inil that you're
going to like necessarily go in the
right direction but it gives you the
possibility to which means you can
increase your Fitness landscape so um
increasing your Fitness landscape also
means acre error like you're going to
make some errors and some parts of you
are going to die so it's sometimes okay
to continue accruing error this is why I
think the the distinction between
degeneracy and and redundancy is
important if you're just expanding
energy for something which literally
doesn't help you right now but is doing
the same thing as something else which
would potentially help help you and it's
not like there's so much redundancy that
let's say given some
error you still wouldn't need it then
it's probably best to pull it away but
if it's doing something else in the
meantime even if it's rowing in the
wrong direction yeah it's it's still
doing something it's still you know um
it's still trying to compute some error
and it's possible that over time you
will find that this is just not a thing
you ever need you will have accured so
much error that you'll just push it away
and this is how your system changes over
time as well you don't just necessarily
like grow as a blob right you sometimes
you just prune you push it away and it
it is good for you to learn that you had
to get rid of it you wouldn't
necessarily know otherwise yeah yeah
it's um stimulating some thoughts
actually because I I guess it's very
similar to friston's idea of of entropy
so you know like maintaining behavioral
complexity because it might be useful
but um there's this thing with gradient
optimization when you do monotonic
gradient optimization you kind of expect
to um just strip away anything that's
not helping me and sometimes you need to
like maintain the the the genery for a
significant amount of time before it
becomes useful later so like in
friston's framework I think it's like
it's keeping it around yeah but for
quite a long
time yes so I think
um I think it's all about the amount of
energy you have as say
Capital
um and I think it touches into something
really interesting about psychology like
hoarders why do hoarders exist like if
you ask them what's the likelihood of
you ever using that thing like ever at
all and they're like well maybe I'll
need it and then you you point out to
them a situation well the situation
happened where you would have needed it
and you still didn't use it now what do
you think and they it just it doesn't
update so to them it's like they don't
have the right capacity to update their
model such that over time even given
that probability and the fact that it
happened Etc they can't prune it um but
if it doesn't cost you anything like you
just have a you have an adapter at home
and you never go to the US but you still
have it and it's like whatever you know
it doesn't cause that much error mhm
Maybe it's worth maintaining the
possibility of a policy which would use
it it's it's it's more about
um given the pool of policies you're
maintaining how much does it cost you to
maintain a policy that goes all the way
over there even though you can tell your
viability is over here you could choose
to do so and maybe it'll be adaptive but
if it isn't effectively the kind of
system that
maintains the wrong balance over the
type of redundancy and and and
degeneracy that it maintains is just
going to yeah it's going to perish
faster than the others yeah yeah well
this has been amazing thank you so much
for chatting with me you're welcome it
was fun